hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner oder
unserer torten welt und wie die sanierer
schon gesagt hat machen wir heute 1 1
und ich werde jetzt heute in diesem
video zwei verschiedene sorten zeigen
und zwar werde ich einmal ein richtiges
machen also mit einer eismaschine und
zeigt euch da aber auch die variante
ohne eismaschine falls ihr eben keine zu
hause habt und am ende des videos zeige
ich euch ein schnelles rezept dass jeder
zu hause machen kann jeder der den mixer
hat und einfach mal ganz schnell lust
auf ein eis hat ich werde zuerst ein
cremiges eis machen und zeigt euch hilfe
einmal die zutaten und zwar brauchen wir
200 gramm sahne 200 milliliter milch und
ich habe zehn frische früchte insgesamt
250 gramm
hier habe ich 175 gramm erdbeeren das
sind deutsche apple und ihr seht auch
die dürfen ruhig sehr reif sein das
heißt nämlich dass sie dann sehr süß
sind
ich habs jetzt schon entstehend und
gewaschen ich habe hier wie gesagt 175
gramm und habe einfach für den
farbklecks noch mal ein paar bombe
angenommen und ein paar himbeeren seht
ihr hier unten drin
die waren tief gefroren habe ich auch so
ein tiefkühl packung heraus und habe sie
etwas aufbauen lassen
und das hier sind 75 also habe ich
insgesamt 250 ihr könnt auch andere
früchte zusammenmischen so wie es euch
am besten gefällt
hier habe ich 130 gramm puderzucker eine
ganz kleine prise salz und hier habe ich
zwei eigelb
ihr könnt natürlich auch statt sahne nur
milch benutzen also nochmal 200
milliliter milch dazu aber in der sahne
steckt ja fett drin
und damit es richtig schön cremig wird
brauchen wir fett und deswegen nimmt man
da auch sahne man kann auch nur seine
nehmen
aber dann finde ich es wieder zu cremig
also da müsste einfach mal selber
abstimmen wie ihr die konsistenz haben
möchtet ich find sie so richtig toll und
offen verwendet im übrigen auch butter
zucker weil das ich einfach schön
auflöst ihr könnt natürlich auch
kristall zu unternehmen müssten aber
ganz lange rühren bis das sich auflöst
mittelfinger und mit puderzucker hat es
einfach besser
und egal ob jetzt eine eismaschine habt
oder nicht die zubereitung dieser creme
masse ich jetzt gleich und ich werde
euch jetzt einfach mal zeigen wie man
diese creme masse vorbereitet und wehrt
euch später dann die hälfte davon in die
eismaschine geben und die hälfte dann
somit hand zubereiten von euch einfach
zeigen wie es auch ohne eismaschine geht
schritt sagen beginnt direkt an die
maschinen und an die küchenzeile und
fangen direkt an
zuerst müssen jetzt die früchte püriert
werden und es können ja einfach in jedem
mixa machen ich nur mit dem thermomix
und ich werde auch ganz oft immer
gefragt wieso ich denen nicht öfter
einsätze in meinen videos
ich mache einfach deswegen nicht weil
viele meiner zuschauer einfach keinen
thermomix haben
aber falls ihr einen thermomix habt und
euch ganz viele thermomix rezepte
wünscht dann schaut doch mal bei der
termin vorbei das ist eine ganz liebe
und jetzt ganz tolle rezepte ich habe
euch auch den link in der infobox
verlinkt und sie hat so viele tolle
rezepte ich glaube da muss ich gar nicht
so viel im thermomix machen und schaut
einfach mal dort verfangen lancieren
ganz lieben gruß von mir da und da
gibt's auf jeden fall ganz ganz viele
thermomix gesagt einschnitten wie gesagt
jedes mit jedem anderen mixa auch es
gibt da halt einfach
qualitätsunterschiede und das ist
einfach quatsch
jutta christoph auch an die werden wir
jetzt ganz kurz vor mixen
dann gebe ich da jetzt das eigelb mit
dazu und dann kommt noch der puderzucker
mit dazu und das ganze wird noch mal
verrührt und viele werden jetzt
vielleicht sagen oh gott ein rohes ei
möchte ich nicht in meinem ipad drin
haben also heute werde ich das wirklich
roh verwenden
nächste woche werde ich euch eine
variante zeigen in der man es nicht mehr
hoch verwendet und natürlich kann man es
auch ohne ei machen aber das ei dient
hier einfach als emulgator und ein
emulator dass ich gar nichts schlimmes
sondern das hilft einfach zwei
verschiedene massen die eigentlich nicht
zusammenbleiben zu binden
zum beispiel hat milch einen natürlichen
emulgator denn milch besteht ja aus fett
und aus wasser und einfach damit es eine
emulsion bildet das eine gemeinsame
flüssigkeit hat es auch in natürlichen
emulgator mit drin
und hier in dem eis brauchen wir eben
das ei oder einen anderen emulgator
kammer auch johannes brot kein mehl
unternehmen aber ich habe jetzt mich für
sich entschieden weil jeder erhält
überall in jedem supermarkt oder am
besten vom bauernhof und dieses bindet
dann einfach die flüssigkeit und das
fett so dass später will mir das eis
dann verzehren dass sich das nicht
schnell auflöst also nicht schmilzt und
dadurch daneben sich die striche
schichten voneinander trennen und es ist
einfach der grund wieso man einnimmt
heute wie gesagt da muss man eben gut
drauf aufpassen dass man vorher die
eierschale gut seubert weil da die
salmonellen darauf sitzen können
aber wenn ihr das alles hygienisch
bearbeitet habt ihr da wirklich gar kein
risiko dass wir da irgendwie salmonellen
im eis mit drin habt und da geht es
jetzt gleich weiter jetzt gebe ich noch
das salz mit rein und es hilft einfach
den süßen geschmack zu heben
und jetzt kommt noch milch und die sahne
mit dazu
und dann werde ich das einfach nur noch
kurz vor mixen und ich werde es jetzt in
meiner hübschen aid machen natürlich
gibt es verschiedene eismaschine und
zwar wie das tier durch passive kälte
gerührt und es gibt auch eismaschine mit
aktiver kälte also die haben dann so ein
kühlaggregat drin sind in einem strom
und dann arbeitet die maschine und kühlt
das eis und rührt es eben währenddessen
da ich aber jetzt nicht so oft mache
reicht für mich so ein passives gerät
also wo das wurde sei es einfach passiv
gerührt wird und zwar ist es einfach ein
aufsatz den muss man vorher einfach so
15 stunden im eis kühlbehälter kühl und
wenn man das weiß kann man es einfach
immer dort lagern
ich habe diesen ice behälter immer im
kühlfach und kann einfach immer wenn ich
jetzt lust davon als hab das ding
rausholen meinen meine ausführungen rein
machen und mein eis rühren
ich werde jetzt die hälfte meines hier
drin machen und die andere hälfte werde
ich ganz normal mit einem schneebesen
rühren so dass sie auch sehen könnt wie
man das ohne eismaschine machen kann
diese eismaschine könnt ihr übrigens
auch bei mir erhalten
da schreibt ihr einfach eine e mail an
info at least orten welt.de und hierbei
ist es jetzt wichtig dass ihr das auf
stufe 1 führt und ich weiß jetzt
anschalten und dann erst die ausfüllung
reingeben einfach damit dass jetzt nicht
am boden gleich anfriert weil dann kann
das gerät hier nicht mehr rühren in die
eismaschine einfüllen
aber ich gebe es wie gesagt nur die
hälfte hier rein
und die andere hälfte weit es in einer
edelstahl schüssel geben
dieses gebe ich jetzt in einem
gefrierfach und zwar solange ihr seht es
hier
ihr müsst auch ein ganz großes
verhältnis nehmen damit es einfach
später beim rühren gut klappt und dieses
gebe ich jetzt einen gefrierschrank und
werden nach etwa einer halben stunde mal
reinschauen
bis am rand so etwa 1 cm schon gefroren
ist dann hole ich es raus bulls durch
und gibt wieder rein dann hole ich es
wieder raus nach einer halben stunde
etwa ist wieder so ein rand angekommen
ist wo es wieder durch und das machen
wir dann so lange bis das eis komplett
gefroren ist und hier könnt ihr dann
sehen dass das eis immer fester wird bei
mir hat es jetzt etwa eine halbe stunde
gedauert
ist das alles wird immer cremiger
hier habe ich jetzt noch ein paar
erdbeeren gestückelt in ganz kleine
würfel und habe sie damit zum einzug
gegeben und das mache ich dann aber auch
erst wenn es etwas fester ist einfach
damit sich die erbbaurecht ich gut in
dem eis verteilen können wenn es dann
fertig ist dürft ihr das gerät
ausschalten und das eis abkratzen und
ihr seht es jetzt das eine ganz weiche
konsistenz aber dabei und sitzt im
küchenstudio das sehr warm war gebe ich
das jetzt einfach noch mal in der große
form das glattstreichen und einfach noch
mal für etwa zwei stunden ins
gefrierfach stellen weil wir jetzt
einfach etwas festere size möchten was
nicht sofort zerschmilzt ihr seht ihr
auch dass man die ice schüssel bis zum
letzten rest auskratzen kann da einfach
das richtig schön glatt ist bevor ich
jetzt im gefrierfach stelle gebe ich
noch eine folie drüber damit einfach
keine gerüche drankommen einsetzen wird
es einfach schön so ein bisschen
angerostet sage ich das jetzt hier seht
ihr das sich schon kleine rand gebildet
hat und dass ich das jetzt einfach mit
dem schneebesen wieder glatt rühren
und jetzt geht es wieder in den
gefrierschrank und wiederholt es jetzt
so lange bis das alles einfach
kompletten vorn ist und es richtig schön
das ist also nichts anderes wie die
einzeln stehende mutter sich eben alles
mit der hand mache und ohne echten
könnte jetzt auch sehen dass ich das
einzelne flache reform gefühlt habe weil
es so einfach viel schneller gefriert
hier habe ich nämlich mehr rand einen
flachen boden von unten kann sich reden
und jetzt gehe ich einfach immer da wenn
der rand wieder da ist
ich zeige euch gleich das einzige fach
und zeigt euch jetzt aber wie immer ganz
schnell ausmachen kann das kann wirklich
jeder der ein mixa hat also einen guten
mix und zwar braucht ihr dafür einfach
ein paar tiefkühl früchte des tisches
mit fertige backmischungen ihr könnt
aber zum beispiel auch einfacher obst
selber einfrieren der kinder bananen
nehmen aprikosen oder einfach auch so
wären also alles was ihr mögt dann
braucht er 80 gramm puderzucker und
etwas joghurt ich habe da jetzt 200
gramm ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel
sahne nehmen oder etwas butter milch
oder einfach irgendwas cremiges jetzt
gebe ich einfach die tiefe früchte in
meinem mixa und werde jetzt einmal schön
verlassen
und jetzt kommt der puderzucker mit dazu
und stecken und dann wird es nochmal
vermixt
und ihr seid jetzt auch hier dass dieses
eis sehr weich geworden ist einfach
durch die temperatur bei uns in der
küche
aber das ist kein problem ich werde das
jetzt einfach noch mal ins gefrierfach
stellen für etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
wenn ihr die tiefkühl früchte direkt
verwendet dann dauert es natürlich nicht
lange dann könnt ihr das als auch sofort
verzehren
und wenn ihr den letzten rechnet
auskratzen könnt gibt einfach noch ein
bisschen milch dazu oder zum beispiel
guter mensch und vermisstes und dann
habt ihr einfach einen milchshake und
dann hab dann richtig leckeren
milchshake ich habe jetzt hier alles
reissorten und west jetzt einfach mal
schön servieren
ich habe dir dein eislöffel und das ist
das eis aus der eismaschine nicht so
richtig schön cremig nehme ich noch hier
und jetzt auch den unterschied mal dass
ich jetzt ist es aus mixa also einfach
die tiefe früchte mit dem joghurt das
schmilzt jetzt auch als erstes das ist
das eis ohne eismaschine das schmilzt
auch schon und das ist das eis aus der
eismaschine das bleibt natürlich länger
jetzt können das einfach mit ein
bisschen kräutern garnieren und freude
aus dass ich jetzt schäfer mensa und
fertig ist euer selbst gemachtes eis
die rezepte gibt es natürlich zum
nachlesen auf sell ist orten welt.de und
ich werde jetzt nächste woche auch noch
mal ein eis machen habe ja gesagt falls
euch interessiert wirklich denn max lohr
ii nachmachen und wehrt euch da noch mal
so einen grund so ein grundrezept für
ein eis geben für eincremen eis und
daraus kann man dann wirklich jeder als
variation machen
ich hoffe dass euch dieses rezept
gefallen hat und falls ihr noch mal bei
diesem schokoladen bisher vorbeischauen
wollte habe ich euch das und in der
infobox auch verlinkt und ich wünsche
euch noch einen ganz schönen tag bis zum
nächsten mal
steht man mich sieht man dich ja die
sich ein toller turm und eine einzogen
drauf optisch sieht ja toll aus super
klasse jetzt auch noch etwas größeres